[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de parlement hebdo l'émission qui
revient sur les temps forts de
l'actualité à l'assemblée nationale et
au sénat et que j'ai le plaisir de vous
présenter avec brigitte boucher bonjour
brigitte un jour tam et cette semaine
est riche elle est marquée par l'arrivée
du nouveau gouvernement castex au
parlement et pour commenter toute cette
actualité notre invité est aujourd'hui
stéphane peut vous êtes député
communiste de seine saint denis et c'est
brigitte qui vous présente
bonjour stéphane peut vous est né à
pauvres dans les pyrénées atlantiques un
certain 24 juillet mais c'est en
seine-saint-denis que vous officiez un
bastion historique du communisme votre
parti de coeur député touche à tout
membre de la commission des lois
on vous connaît surtout pour vos prises
de parole sur la défense de votre
territoire le plus pauvre de france ou
sur le logement
un secteur où vous avez pris votre élan
à l'assemblée élan pour évolution du
logement de l'aménagement et du
numérique
c'était le nom de la loi que vous avez
largement tenter d'amender alors votre
signe distinctif vous aimez cultivez
votre jardin
au sens propre comme au sens figuré chez
les communistes c'est forcément un
jardin partagé pour la collectivité mais
cultivez votre jardin ça vous permet
sûrement de garder la tête froide en
politique c'est quoi votre secret
d'essayer d'avoir en permanence le recul
alors cultiver son jardin c'est au sens
propre
j'essaye de d'avoir de temps en temps je
pense avoir la main verte donc de temps
en temps je l'entretiens cette main
verte
et puis de prendre le recul de 2 de
continuer à lire d'essayer autant que
faire ce peu d'aller en ce moment
c'était difficile d'aller au théâtre de
de prendre un peu le recul est de
toujours avoir la pensée pour les gens
conclut que l'on sert c'est à dire que
quand on est pris dans le tourbillon de
la vie parlementaire avoir une pensée
pour les gens de saint denis de
pierrefitte et de villetaneuse tous ces
visages que l'on croise ces courants
chez les parlementaires j'espère qu'on
est nombreux à le faire
en tout cas quand vous avez été comme
moi 25 ans élu local
forcément le nombre de visages que vous
en tête est forcément très une très très
très nombreux on va parler en tout cas à
des nouveaux visages du gouvernement
cette semaine d'abord baptême du feu
pour le premier ministre et son nouveau
gouvernement à l'assemblée jean castex
et ses ministres ont répondu aux tirs
nourris des députés de l'opposition lors
des questions au gouvernement la
commission d' enquête sur la gestion de
la crise de lakovic 19 poursuit ses
auditions à l'assemblée cette semaine
martin hirsch a répondu aux attaques du
professeur out et on finira par le
rapport du sénat qui s'alarment d'un
risque de radicalisation islamiste et
qui propose 44 mesures pour lutter
contre cette menace qu'ils jugent
inquiétante
et pour commencer cette émission
première séance pour jean castex à
l'assemblée
[Musique]
jean castex et les nouveaux ministres
ont fait leurs premiers pas à
l'assemblée cette semaine une première
séance de questions au gouvernement où
l'opposition n'a pas retenu ses coups
elsa mandingue avant le baptême du feu
pour le premier ministre jean castex
dans l'arène de l'hémicycle je souhaite
la bienvenue dans notre hémicycle au
premier ministre et aux membres du
nouveau gouvernement
pour sa première séance de questions au
gouvernement
je voudrais d'abord vous dire toute
l'émotion et tout l'honneur que je
ressens m'exprimant aujourd'hui pour la
première fois devant vous voilà pour les
présentations
puis vient le vif du sujet monsieur le
premier ministre le président de la
république vous a confié je le cite la
responsabilité de tracer un nouveau
chemin pour notre pays
pensez vous que ce nouveau chemin soit
compatible avec le maintien de la
réforme des retraites dès cette semaine
je recevrai l'ensemble des partenaires
sociaux
mon objectif est de mettre tous les
sujets sur la table
autre prestation attendue celle du
nouveau garde des sceaux eric dupond
moretti
bousculé par l'opposition
cellou mais laissez moi
monsieur le député j'ai un sens aigu du
contradictoire et du respect de la
parole de l'autre j'aimerais que vous me
laissiez au moins exprimer
on pardonne et moi on ne juge on ne peut
mieux le député je voudrais vous
répondre complètement
on ne juge pas des hommes sur des a
priori me semble-t-il
vous me jugerez sur ce que j'ai fait
quand je l'aurai fait nouveau visage
personnalités déjà connu anciens députés
ont complété le testing de ce nouveau
gouvernement
stéphane peu quelle impression vous a
fait nouveau premier ministre et son
gouvernement
c'était très curieux cette séance des
questions au gouvernement parce que on
avait un premier ministre qui a pompé
beaucoup d'air en faisant des réponses
très longue et très creuse alors c'est
pas la qualité de l'homme qui est en
cause je pense pas un truc ce qui est en
cause c'est quand même avec lui un très
longue et très creuse
ouais ouais je crois que jean luc
mélenchon une expression produire les
arbres ans le temps de pousser entre les
mots bon c'est voilà c'était une autre
façon de dire comment ces deux là
forment le web mais non mais pas
seulement justement c'est pas que de la
forme c'est que si vous voulez on est
dos quand même dans un paradoxe puisque
on est dans une émission qui s'appelle
parlement hebdo deux parlements et
encore une énième fois abaissées par
quelque chose qui est assez peu
commentée à ma grande surprise dans la
vème république le gouvernement il est
redevable devant l'assemblée et devant
le parlement
pas de vent de président de la
république c'est la raison pour laquelle
plusieurs fois pendant la cinquième
république nous avons eu des
cohabitations quand la majorité de
l'assemblée nationale changer de
gouvernement changé et le président
restait bon là vous avez un président de
la république qui demande à son premier
ministre nommé et à son gouvernement de
suspendre sa déclaration de politique
générale de suspendre le vote de
confiance de l'assemblée qui est
normalement l'acte déclencheur de
l'action du gouvernement est de le
suspendre au discours du président de la
république qui doit avoir lieu le 14
juillet
renvoyant la discussion de politiser le
débat de politique générale après le 14
juillet laisse pas la semaine prochaine
et donc forcément nous avons une
situation où entre des deux vous avez un
gouvernement qui est nommé qui ne peut
rien dire que c'est un mépris
jce latif hybride du parlement bien sûr
c'est un acte supplémentaire d'une
présidentialisation du pouvoir d'une
concentration des pouvoirs dans les
mains d'un seul homme et moi au delà des
jugements qu'on peut avoir à l'endroit
où à l'encontre 2000 emmanuel macron je
pense que c'est une dérive de nos
institutions qui porte en germe un
affaiblissement de la demande et dans
d'autres pays rien non plus jean castex
par exemple il a annoncé cette semaine
vouloir rouvrir le dossier des retraites
d'ailleurs n'at-il pas raison vouloir
régler la question urgente du
financement alors que le déficit plonge
à 30 milliards en 2020 ça c'était une
annonce quand même qu'il a fait cette
semaine et mais bon d'abord vous n'avez
vu le formidable accueil que lui ont
réservé les partenaires sociaux hier qui
ont été reçus un du medef à la cfdt en
passant par la cgt toutes les forces
syndicales lui dis je l'écoutais à faire
absolument pas raisonnable c'est
absolument pas à l'ordre du jour ce qui
est à l'ordre du jour de notre dans
notre pays au sortir de la crise
sanitaire qui d'ailleurs pas
complètement terminée et qui peut
rebondir
c'est de faire face à la crise sociale
est d'avoir qu'un seul leitmotiv
quinquin qu'un seul accès le plan de
relance et la question de l'emploi et
surtout pas de remettre sur la table une
réforme qui risque de diviser les
français fait vous savez le déficit des
retraites d'abord il est très lié de
très lié à l'activité économique et donc
la seule question pour les toutes les
autres actrices telles activités bien
sûr bien sûr et et par conséquence la
reprise de l'activité la façon dans
notre pays va subir dans quelles
proportions la crise économique et la
crise sociale dans les prochaines
semaines deere a aussi beaucoup de
choses sur la capacité de notre système
social de se maintenir
il ya la cgt qui appelle à manifester et
à faire grève déjà pour le 17 septembre
vous aussi vous vous appeler à la grève
bon moi je n'appelle pas à la grève
parce que je suis passé de calais je
suis parlementaire donc mais ça m'arrive
de 10 participer de les soutenir donc je
dis ça c'est pas seulement sous la forme
d'une boutade c'est que je suis attaché
à ce que chacun soit dans son rôle et je
pense que trop souvent les politiques
ont empiété sur le rôle des syndicats
quel que soit bon donc mais vous
souhaitez cette initiative
oui parce que si vous voulez d'abord
l'appel de la cgt si j'ai bien compris
n'est pas que sur les retraites il est
sur les questions de l'emploi
il est quand même sur une question qui
interroge beaucoup nos concitoyens c'est
comment se fait-il qu'il y ait autant
dette publique de verser aux entreprises
et aussi peu de conditionnalité à cm2 à
sézanne public comment des entreprises
qui reçoivent des centaines de millions
voire des milliards d'êtres public à
peine d'encaisser le chèque des
contribuables français déposent des
plans de licenciements massifs c'est
quand même un souci je pense que ça fait
partie des mots d'ordre de la grève du
17 la semaine prochaine y aura le
discours de politique générale on en a
on en a parlé
est ce que vous pourriez envisager de
voter la confiance au gouvernement
castex où vous êtes déjà fait une idée
non franchement y'a pas de faux suspense
vous savez moi je comprends toujours pas
ce remaniement
il ya normalement il ya deux raisons
pour remanier soit vous changez de cap
et politique d'orientation politique et
donc vous remaniée votre gouvernement
pour ce nouvel cette nouvelle
orientation politique
emmanuel macron a clos le débat puisque
dans son interview à la presse
quotidienne régionale
il a dit continuité de mes orientations
de 2010 suffit mois pour savoir que je
ne voterait pas la confiance que j'ai un
désaccord profond avec les orientations
qui sont celles du président de la
république est ce qu il ya une deuxième
raison c'est un premier ministre
totalement éreinté usées qu'on peut plus
et donc il faut lui donner du sang neuf
cela c'était la verse et grimper dans
les sondages à présent de la république
qui baissaient et on le change
donc il n'y a aucune raison une logique
politique de vouloir casser la droite
non moi j'ai l'impression que le manuel
macron il n'a pas mis en place un
gouvernement avec ce remaniement il a
mis en place une équipe de campagne
électorale jacques jean castex en tout
cas est donc le nouveau premier
istres mais il ya une autre star qui a
focalisé l'attention cette semaine dans
l'hémicycle l'ex ténor du barreau et
nouveau garde des sceaux eric
dupond-moretti écouter son échange au
sénat avec le président de la commission
des lois lors des questions d'actualité
vous serez bien évidemment conviés nous
parlerons ensemble de cela j'envisage
très prochainement de recevoir tous les
président e du groupe
jeudi tous les présidents de groupe g
comment vous le dire autrement peu
besoin de vous monsieur le ministre vous
allez nous recevoir et nous nous allons
vous auditionné après la déclaration de
politique générale du premier ministre
nous sommes pressés de vous entendre
nous voulons rentrer dans les détails
vous avez mis la barre haut et même
peut-être très haut c'est la bonne
altitude et maintenant à vous de la
franchir
voilà pour ce bon mot de philippe bas
les sénateurs ont ils raison de vouloir
auditionner eric dupond-moretti au plus
vite ils veulent notamment l'entente sur
la question de l'indépendance du parquet
parce que lorsqu'il était avocat et
s'est dit favorable au maintien d'un
lien justement entre l'exécutif et le
parquet alors un les sénateurs ont
raison de d'auditionner le garde des
sceaux face à ça avec tous les garde des
sceaux donc pas de raison que celui ci
allait donc c'est valable pour le sénat
c'est valable aussi pour l'assemblée
l'audition de monsieur dupont moretti
par la commission des lois de
l'assemblée nationale
ce sera le lundi 20 à 17 heures 30 dans
l'enceinte de l'assemblée nationale je
suis membre de la commission des lois
donc je serai présent lors de cette
audition et je compte bien lui poser un
certain nombre de questions c'est normal
et j'apprécie le bon mot de monsieur bah
vous nous recevrait mais nous on vous
auditionnera il aura pu même dire on
vous convoquera et il faut que les
membres du gouvernement malgré tout ce
que j'ai dit précédemment sachent et
comprennent un solide qui son rôle de la
semaine le rôle de l'assemblée nationale
vous allez lui poser qu'est ce que vous
voulez savoir quelle est sa queue bon
quelle est sa feuille de route il arrive
j'imagine qu'il a réfléchi on va pas lui
faire trop de mauvais procès surtout ce
qu'il a pu dire auparavant parce qu'un
avis pour moretti était un avocat bavard
vous allez me dire c'est un peu voilà
c'est un avocat il a dit beaucoup de
choses et bon franchement je vais pas on
va pas les ressortir sur tous les sujets
les propos de direct dupond-moretti
parce que bon n'en finirait pas et le
pauvre il centre avec moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est qu'on est dans un pays
où la justice est l'institution publique
la plus décriée par les français dans
laquelle ils ont l'institution dans
laquelle ils ont le moins confiance et
quand même un grand problème pour notre
pays 2 nous sommes dans le peloton de
queue des pays européens sur les moyens
consacrés à la justice c'est une semaine
à la ville tribunal de bobigny pendant
laquelle jean castex a à la fois défendu
son choix de ministre mais il a aussi
annoncé plus de moyens pour la justice à
ce que ça vous en réjouissez
l'accélération de la loi de
programmation et vous savez moi je suis
un député de la seine-saint-denis gt
nous participe à un rapport
parlementaire sur les ruptures d'égalité
républicaine j'étais mercredi à la
visite du premier ministre et du garde
des sceaux à bobigny qu'est le dépôt
deuxième tribunal de france et le plus
exemple en moyens actes et où nous
sommes le département la seine saint
denis qui bat tous les records de
visites ministérielles en gros on a un
ministre par jour dans sonic
donc si vous voulez je dirais je dirais
pas qu on est blasé mais enfin vous
savez des ministres qui défilent en
seine saint denis c'est pas loin ça va
10 km de paris des fois ils ont
l'impression que c'est un exotique qui
voit un autre monde à bord mais nous on
en a marre si vous voulez en
seine-saint-denis donc moi je l'avais
dit lors du rapport parlementaire je
l'avais dit à edouard philippe lorsqu'il
était venu écouter dites à vos ministres
qui viennent - et que quand ils viennent
ils viennent avec des choses du sonnant
et du trébuchet
voilà nous on n'est pas un zoo la
seine-saint-denis où on vient se
distraire le temps d'une après-midi et
et remplir sa feuille de route en termes
de visites de terrain pour les ministres
non nous on est un département qui
souffre c'est un département qu'un
immense potentiel parce que cette
département le plus jeune de france le
plus dynamique mais en même temps qu'ils
rencontrent
or moments de difficulté donc il faut
que la france parie sur ce département
les outils pour ça vous pensez que c'est
l'homme de la situation
écoutez on a fait un rapport
parlementaire qui pointait le caractère
de clochardisation de la justice en
seine saint denis
donc voilà il ya une immense espérance
républicaine en seine-saint-denis il
faut que la république tienne sa
promesse pour l'instant elle la tient
pas et soit laquelle soin d'ajouter
alors il nous dit des moyens il n'a pas
tout à fait dit ça mercredi il a dit
jean temps j'écoute je vais voir bon le
premier ministre alors que c'est pas
normal de travailler dans ces conditions
là bon ok d'accord très bien merci de
votre émotion mais vous êtes aux
manettes et au gouvernement nous vous
demandons n'ont pas de l'émotion mais
des actes et des actes on poursuit cette
émission avec la commission d' enquête
sur la gestion de la crise de lakovic 19
[Musique]
et cette semaine place aux personnels
soignants et aux responsables de
l'hôpital public ils ont répondu aux
questions des députés de la commission
denquête qu'ovide martin hirsch le
directeur de l'ap-hp en a profité pour
s'adresser directement à didier raoul
les précisions de stéphanie des pierres
quelques jours avant son audition martin
hirsch a accusé didier rahout de faux
témoignage devant la commission denquête
le professeur marseillais avait affirmé
que la mortalité était trois fois plus
forte à paris qu'à marseille
sous-entendu parce que les hôpitaux
parisiens ne prescrit mais pas de
chloroquine faux a rétorqué martin
hirsch
il affirme que le document cité par
didier raoul tu viens bien de l'ap-hp
mais qu'il est obsolète et incomplet le
taux de mortalité dans les services de
soins critiques de l'ap-hp ne sont pas
de 43%
nous estimons aujourd'hui que le taux de
mortalité pour être de 31 à 35 %
le lendemain parole aux soignants cinq
syndicats raconte l'épidémie
les députés cherchent à savoir si tous
les malades ont été accueillis dans les
hôpitaux comme l'expliquent les
autorités sanitaires ou s'il ya eu du
tri dans les ehpad où les chu selon
l'âge des passions là les soignantes ne
sont pas du même avis y'a aucun moment
je n'ai vu un médecin dira j'ai deux
passions
je choisis lequel tient passion ne
rentre par animation c'est pas parce
qu'on n'a pas dit c'est parce que
derrière il peut avoir des conséquences
très graves pour lui et qu'on sait que
c'est difficile de se relever de ne
serait-ce que deux semaines de
réanimation moi je pense que des choix
ont été faits on a jugé que des patients
mais essentiellement parce qu'ils
étaient âgés avaient une balance
bénéfice risque effectivement d'une
entrée en réanimation qui
permettait de dire aux réanimateurs qu'
il aurait du mal à les sortir de
de réanimation les députés finiront la
première partie de leur enquête le 28
juillet avec l'audition très attendue
d'olivier verront le ministre de la
santé
ses fans que les communistes souhaité
une commission d' enquête sur la gestion
de la crise de lakovic 19 au vue des
auditions qui se passe là même si ce
sont les républicains qui sont
rapporteur est ce que vous trouvez
qu'elle est utile oui oui je pense oui
elle et elle est utile d'ailleurs à peu
patiemment il ya quand même un certain
nombre de vérités qui se font jour il ya
au moins je crois au moins trois la
première c'est qu'il ya eu une faute
d'anticipation il ya eu quand même
beaucoup d' alerte de la banque mondiale
de l'organisation mondiale de la santé
qui datait de certaines de septembre
d'octobre afin qu'ils n'ont absolument
pas été prises en compte par le
gouvernement manque d'anticipation aussi
par nos représentants diplomatiques en
chine qui n'ont pas encore pu alerter de
le pays sur ce qui se passait qui
auraient pu nous permettre de nous
prémunir davantage donc il ya une vraie
faute d'anticipation qui ce qui met mise
à jour il ya la politique des masques
enfin franchement le changement de
doctrine de 2013 avec cette destruction
massive la séparation il ya des
institutions de d'anticipation des
grandes crises épidémique qui existaient
qui ont été supprimés noyer dans santé
publique france et qui ont fait que
notre pays s'est désarmé dans la
capacité d'anticipation et d'analystes
donc on voit bien que la france après
par des mesures beaucoup liés aux
politiques d'austérité de ces 10-15
dernières années a baissé la garde et
c'est un peu retrouvé démuni
vous aviez déposé une demande de
commission denquête plus
particulièrement sur la surmortalité de
là que 8,19 en seine saint denis
vous en êtes où alors on a déposé une
coalition à quatre parce que je voulais
y est nous comment expliquer que le
département le plus jeune de france et
celui qui a eu la plus forte
surmortalité d'une maladie dont on dit
qu'elle touche en premier lieu les
personnes fragiles et les seniors bon
donc il ya d'hôpitaux il ya moins de
soignants
alors il
il ya sûrement il ya la population
elle-même qui a été très mobilisés en
première et en deuxième ligne pendant la
crise du coc vide en travaillant
beaucoup nombreux dans des périodes il y
avait très peu de protection il y à des
maladies liées des comorbidités liées à
la pauvreté il faut notamment à
l'obésité le diabète etc
et puis il ya un grand sujet qui mérite
d'être investiguer et qu'il n'avait pas
été par la commission par le rapport
parlementaire qui avait étudié
uniquement éducation justice police avec
cette commission denquête rajoutant à la
sorte et combien d'habitants de la seine
saint denis n'ont pas de médecin
traitant
beaucoup comment se fait-il qu'un
département aussi urbanisé que ça au
coeur de la métropole de parisienne soit
un désert médical en médecine de ville
pourquoi 3 x man biais de réanimation
par habitant en seine saint denis qu'il
y en a dans le val de marne dans les
hauts-de-seine qui sont deux
départements limitrophes
etc etc donc oui là aussi la rupture des
gars comme en cause un pied de la
commission denquête alors j'ai demandé
puisque nous pourrons pouvez pas
utiliser dans notre jargon le droit de
tirage de notre groupe j'ai demandé à
eric ciotti à brigitte bourguignon
encore présidente de cette commission
enquête de nous de nous permettre
d'avoir un une note additive à la
commission denquête de façon à pouvoir
mener les la petite dizaine d'auditions
sur le sujet spécifique de la seine
saint denis dans les problèmes que vous
avez pointé et qui ressort de cette
commission d'enquêté un problème de
financement de d'austérité depuis
plusieurs années c'est ce que vous dites
là les soignants réclamer des hausses de
salaires ya ce ségur de la santé qui
s'achève 7 milliards et demi d'euros
pour les salaires qui ont été mis sur la
table
vous trouvez que c'est un bel effort
vous le saluer c'est un effort c'est
évident mais j'écoute les professionnels
de santé oms
on est on est loin du compte vous savez
les mâles même les primes qui était
prévu pour les salariées de la santé qui
étaient au front pendant le coït pour
l'instant dans certains secteurs ils
l'ont toujours pas perçu là il y avait
une demande des salariés de la santé qui
était une demande de rattrapage qui les
mettaient à 300 euros d'augmentation
ces deux fois 90 euros pour l'année et
demie qui vient on est loin du compte
même si c'est une avancée allez pour
finir le rapport choc du sénat sur la
radicalisation islamiste
[Musique]
après 70 auditions de chercheurs
d'institutions et d'associatifs la
commission d' enquête sur la
radicalisation islamiste créé à la
demande du groupe
heller s'alarme et estime que ce
phénomène est une véritable menace en
france
alizée boissin après 60 heures
d'audition et 8 mois de travail les
sénateurs ont rendu leurs conclusions
sur un sujet sensible la radicalisation
islamiste à l'origine de la commission
denquête le groupe l'est républicain et
la volonté de freiner la propagation des
listes communautaires aux élections
municipales il était nécessaire de ne
plus être dans le déni
nous savons que nous avions
et que nous avons des problématiques par
rapport à un petit groupe d'individus ou
un projet parfois plus collectif de
vouloir imposer une norme religieuse au
dessus des lois de la république
cinq mois après le début des auditions
le constat est alarmant pour cette
sénatrice
oui l'islam politique existe oui le
radicalisme islamique existe c'est un
sujet dont on ne connaît plus tabou
aujourd'hui pour lutter au mieux contre
la radicalisation la commission formule
une quarantaine de propositions parmi
elles l'amélioration du renseignement
territoriales en effet lors des
auditions la commission s'est rendu
compte qu'aucune donnée sérieuse
n'existait pour mesurer l'ampleur de la
radicalisation
un manque que les sénatrices pointe du
doigt autres propositions le traçage des
financement des lieux de culte
le but limiter l'influencé de certains
pays étrangers notamment lors de la
création de mosquées l'autre grande
inquiétude pour les sénateurs de la
commission
les jeunes ils demandent un meilleur
contrôle des écoles hors contrats aidés
élèves non scolarisés enfin il souhaite
une meilleure formation des élus locaux
sur ce sujet qu'à des élus qui
connaissent pas ce sujet ou alors qu'ils
font face de manière un peu brutale sans
en comprendre la finalité pour l'instant
pas de proposition de loi en vue
le rapport sera transmis au président de
la république les conclusions de ce
rapport signé à chacune des stages
brigneau ont été jugés plutôt
caricatural par le gouvernement ce que
c'est difficile de parler de ce
phénomène sont stigmatisés elle est
musulman et stéphane peu oui oui c'est
pas facile parce que si vous voulez tout
ce qui vise à mettre la fois au dessus
de la loi pour reprendre l'expression du
ministre de l'intérieur doit faire
l'objet de beaucoup de vigilance de
rappeler le principe de laïcité
moi j'ai toujours un doute quand on
stigmatise une religion en particulier
non pas qu'elles ne posent pas dans
certains cas des problèmes mais c'est
vraiment une menace pour vous en france
la radicalisation islamiste dans les
quartiers moi je regarde enfin je
regarde mes conclusions du rapport
sénatorial par exemple ils disent jeu
le dis d'autant plus volontiers que j'ai
fait cette demande avec georges fenech
ancien sur parlementaire c'est la mise
en place de ce qu'on appelle la
miviludes qui est quand même l'organisme
qui nous permet de lutter contre les
pratiques sectaires mois à saint denis
j'ai le siège européen de la
scientologie qui s'installe à deux pas
du stade de france
deux pas du stade de france avec un seul
objectif avoir une vitrine de la
scientologie pendant les jeux olympiques
de 2024
parce que le bâtiment donne juste sur le
stade de france est bon il y a plus
d'organismes français fermeture où on a
demandé sa fermeture on n'y arrive pas
on n'y arrive pas la miviludes n'existe
plus donc là je donne un apport dit vrai
il ya des choses sur les banques donc ce
rapport dit vrai mais il faut que tous
ceux qui sont dans un séparatisme
vis-à-vis de la république que ce soit
l'islam politique que ce soit certaines
pratiques évangélistes qui progresse à
grands pas dans dans nos quartiers tous
ceux qui veulent éduquer leurs enfants
en dehors de l'école de la république
il faut faire très attention et ne pas
stygmatiser dira uniquement l'islam
parce que c'est un problème
malheureusement beaucoup plus large
merci stéphane peu d'avoir été avec nous
merci d'un merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivi rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
parlement hebdo
[Musique]